c'est un jeune homme de 32 ans nous
l'appellerons bas car ils fument le
tabac chimique depuis des années il lui
suffit de tirer quelques bouffées pour
se retrouver complètement défoncée et
comprend rien là vous voyez bien que
rien faire il paie rien faire il dort 10
à nadine lui j'essaie parle aujourd'hui
un visage découvert moi aussi j'étais
dans cet état là oui car il veut
témoigner et raconter dans quel enfer la
plongée le tabac chimie en fin de compte
c'était que ça j'avais pas une autre vie
visual dollars
son agression de mangane c'est aux
urgences du centre hospitalier de
bellepierre que nous avons fait la
connaissance de native ce qui se passe
là nine raconte alors qu'il fume le
tabac chimique depuis 2012 et qu'il a
décidé d'arrêter gauche
pourquoi je conseille parce que je me
sens pas bien je vois comme j'ai arrêté
je vois ce g2 vous laisse manger de mal
vous examinez l'examen dure quelques
minutes
ce soir-là nadine repartira avec
quelques médicaments pour l'aider à
tenir en attendant un rendez vous avec
un médecin spécialisé
qu'est ce qui t'as décidé la nature ce
qui m'a décidé de changer c'est ma femme
et mes enfants quoi ils me voient pas
ils me voient que le sort et le sort
qu'on me voit il voit scène une personne
be1
ils ont peur de moi c'est pour cela que
je me suis décidé de me faire soigner
le lendemain nous retrouvant nadine à
sainte clotilde
il veut nous prouver à quel point il est
facile d'acheter du tabac chimiques
là on va aller s'asseoir là bas on
attend que ça se passait bien mais le
truc et c'est ici même le tabac
chimiques c'est là ça se vend ici nous
nous essayons alors nous discutons un
peu ou légèrement que vous avez vous
bien
vous m'avez rencontré à l'hôpital vous
avez vu comment j'étais mais soudain
tous deux jeunes viennent s'asseoir en
face de nous j'étais déjà
fm le pourquoi
quelques minutes plus tard les images se
retrouveront sur snapshot et tout le
monde dans le quartier saura que nadeem
se balade avec une équipe de télévision
mais lui ne se laisse pas démonter quand
des habitants au loin ils interpellent
donner parce que franchement pas ce que
me voyais que moi je t'ai consommateurs
mois moi j'étais un consommateur moi je
fumais car nadine avait l'habitude de
fumer le tabac chimiques juste au pied
de ces immeubles
nadine retourne alors vers les petits
groupes de jeunes au pied des immeubles
le wedge aux as et un médecin one to one
mais selon wang
la voile est amusant vous en parlera la
voile et chimiques ich inc est un pays
où ils sont contents ils sont pas
contents c'est leur problème je m'en
fous pour trouver des vendeurs
nous préférons attendre que la nuit soit
on est
nadine nous emmène vers le lieu de vente
du chef-lieu la base militaire comme
disent certains jeunes
nadine va tenter d'aller acheter une
dose de tabac chimiques
c'est un vaste parking désert à cette
heure là nous nous postons au loin et
apercevant des petits groupes de jeunes
qui vont et viennent
une dose coûte 10 euros et permet de
rouler 2 juin apparemment les jeunes se
passe de la marchandise mais à cette
distance ne pouvons pas distinguer de
quoi il s'agit nadine lui reste
invisible
il a finalement décidé de faire demi
tour de peur que nous ayons été repérés
[Musique]
il nous emmène à présent chez un de ses
meilleurs ennemis aujourd'hui c'est sa
mère qui nous a conduits ça c'est un
camarade quand même un frère pour moi
là je le voilà maintenant il dort il y
as a marqué là son père voyez que c'est
pas normal c'est comme ça dans mon
mouvement euros ça ne s'oublie pas
j'avoue que c'était aux moyens ou saas
et douvres avola alors non quand il
ouvre les yeux
nous craignons qu'en apercevant une
caméra pointée sur lui bakar réagissent
violemment mais la seule chose qu'il a
en tête à ce moment c'est trouver son
reste de juin et fumé quelques bouffées
encore bakar se retourne alors trouve
son sachet de tabac chimiques et sans
aucune gêne devant sa mère devant son
père gravement malade avec ses frères et
soeurs qui joue dans la chambre à côté
il se roule à nouveau joints même sonné
la voile et bien même son nez rabin plus
rien dire mais l'occulté son truc mais
il n'arrive pas tellement le drogué il
est plus fort que lui il est plus fort
que lui dès qu'il a gagné il finira été
et puis pour idole c'est comme ça départ
d'iodé passé pour vous
- il pu faire une à l'ennemi le rhône
puisque ça nous quittons bakar et sa
famille en promettant d'obtenir pour lui
a rendez vous chez le médecin
mais le lendemain c'est nadine que nous
accompagnons au chu de bellepierre
il a rendez-vous cet après-midi voyant
très avec le spécialiste réunionnais de
l'addictologie
david mété je vous en prie installez
vous qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce qui vous
amène aujourd'hui nadine lui raconte
alors ces années de tabac chimiques
je commence à charbon n'a pas senti
témoignages il et il est très précieux
parce que ce qu'on a vu ces derniers
temps c'est c'est vraiment un peu des
choses assez inquiétante et pour pas mal
de gens des gens voient ça comme quelque
chose de deux plutôt de plutôt marrant
de plutôt rigolo et comme un effet
puissant le dr mété montre alors sur son
ordinateur
une vidéo qui a beaucoup tourné sur
internet un très jeune garçon à saint
louis qui tire quelques coups sur une
cigarette
là ça commence sur le tomtom car c'est
une des caractéristiques de la chimie
elle monte au cerveau en quelques
secondes
la saison du corps est dans un produit
qui est un cannabinoïde alors qu'ils
ressemblent et thc autrement dit au
zamal et qui peut être 20 200 fois plus
puissant que les effets du cannabis qui
normalement calme reposé toomelah qui
sont tellement amplifier ou ça se
transforme un espèce de truc qu'on vous
êtes bloqués comme un z bloqué en état
catatonique watan
la relation qu'il est paralysé ah oui ah
oui grave que ce que j'ai
malheureusement ce type de produit
peuvent être assez facilement
accessibles sur sur internet souvent
fabriqués en chine
cette substance elle arrive pur chez le
ch et le dealer qui là qu'il a commandés
et le dealer va dissoudre cette
substance qui va vaporiser donc avec une
quantité minime de produits vaporiser
sur un mélange de plantes à fumer ce qui
est souvent du tabac chez nous à la
réunion et ce tabac à fumer va donner un
effet très très très rapide
la consultation s'achève moi je pense
que vraiment votre démarche
elle et elle est dans le bon sens nous
avait fait part ce déclic que vous avez
eu la part la plus importante de travail
le médecin propose à nadine de le revoir
régulièrement à l'est aujourd'hui
cela fait un mois que nadine n'a plus
fumée de tabac chimiques son ami bakar
lui a rendez vous avec le docteur
mettait la semaine prochaine